the clock on the wall on the seventh day of
December 1941 it struck the eleventh hour
every hour after that has been will be zero hours
48 united states of a free and sovereign America
are at war every American has his job to do and
the will to do it and the tools to do it with
pray God he also has the time time the most vital
natural resource of a country at war every tick of
the clock is time won or lost every 60 minutes
sweep every 12 hour tour of those relentless
hands is turning out carload lots of time for
us to use ourselves or to give away to the enemy
all the scientific devices of chronology
are machined manufacturing time the told
that in All Hands main victory and our
hands must be as we lent lasat the hands
of our clocks they cannot afford to
be left sunrise over Republic Steel
i noon at Willow Run Sun fall
on the electric pole company
midnight at the Brooklyn Navy Yard daunted us and
back to dawn again three eight-hour shifts one day
so much can be done in a day of Americans will
keep their sleeves rolled up inside of 24 hours
one twentieth of a freighter or a tanker can
be built within those same 24 hours a squadron
of tanks can roll off the assembly line and a
flight of bombers can be made ready from radio
to rudder boat in one day a thousand acres of
corn can become 30,000 bushels of food in one
day one plant unit can turn out enough rifles
to equip of Italian of infantry the men who in
one day might win a war or losing oh well let's
visit upstate at a factory where they make 30
caliber rifle cartridges for the army let's
visit gene one of the girls to inspect these
cartridges before they're shipped she's a good
kid loves her country and a guy named Joe he
gave her that pin she's wearing before he went to
Australia she's a good kid honest intelligent but
she gets tired in the afternoon sometimes like
to take extra time off for a smoke that's all
only a few minutes a few minutes it only takes a
second to jar the primer out of a cartridge and it
only takes a second to put an old ke ticket
on a lot that should have been rejected a
cartridge without a primer is one
that will never fire it's about
as useful and a rifle as a cigarette
or as the minutes that go up in its
smoke one bad cartridge one chance in a
million to get by undetected one second
in sixty one girl out of a hundred who is
an honors patriotic intelligence saboteur
yes gene is intelligent intelligent enough to
know that one of these bullets in good condition
can travel three miles but she doesn't know that
a defective one can go halfway around the world
somewhere in the Pacific somewhere between the
devil and the Dutch East India is an American
scouting patrol too bad about that cartridge
missing fire it should have been rejected it would
have been too if a girl named Jean hadn't taken
time out to smoke now meet JG general manager of
a large wholesale food house makes twelve thousand
a year worn a white collar all his life that is
except for the khaki one he wore 1918 trying to
get in this scrap after Pearl Harbor but they
said his son could handle the fighting orders
and he could go on taking food orders like this
fifty cases of 14 a one that's code for lifeboat
provisions notify Martin that means ship on Monday
too old too old to fight for not too old to
work yourself silly trying to get out orders
and priorities on time time holy mackerel
it's 2:30 I have to rush like old Harry to
make it but a tell Mabel where I'll be why
bother it's Saturday that lifeboat stuff
doesn't go out till Monday nothing can come up
over the weekend besides I've got an important
engagement with a couple of guy important
engagement with a couple of guys a couple of
guys on the home team well they are leading
the league and it is first out of the often
four months and there's nothing that can't wait
nine innings nothing that is except time time
and time and convoys a change in sailing orders
and an urgent wiring cold like both supplies to
be shipped at once chips by a man who was
busy coaching at first base unfortunately a
convoy can't wait for the last inning a convoy
wait for the time and a tide wait for no man
standing beside a lifeboat only partly
provision six American Flyers fail for
Ireland in convoy on a freighter that
falls behind its escort it's an old story
six men sales for Ireland two
of them got there one of them
out of his mind the other one dead 25
days in a boat provision for ten days
the tide rolls in jgies and the clock ticked
on and neither one in peace or war will wait
for nine innings the state of North Australia
is twenty three time zones away from the state
of Michigan and the clock in the cockpit of a
plane over Darwin and the watch on the wrist
of the officer in New Guinea are synchronized
with the clock at the door of the factory in
Detroit and geared to the clock over the
water cooler in Kalamazoo the production
rate of our factories and the firing rate of
our guns is synchronized by one machine the
clock this is a machine that manufactures
victory turning out thirty two and a half
million seconds each year each separate tick
a precious tool to use and building our future
and you these are your tools your hands and
they must be as relentless as the hands of
your clocks if we are to conquer
they cannot afford to be less yeah
everybody
Oh
you know